CLAIRE SLATTERY: Hello, and
welcome to public speaking
pro tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
We help people turn the
mundane into the memorable.
ARJITA SETHI: Challenges
into insights.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And
presentations into performance.
ARJITA SETHI: And we do
that with something we
call improv thinking.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: We'll give
you exercises and insights
to help you become more agile,
more confident, and more
engaging.
Which brings us to our
first core principle--
if you are a presenter,
you are a performer.
ARJITA SETHI: If you're speaking
in front of an audience of 300,
or one on one, or team meeting,
or even just on video camera,
then you are a performer.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: That's right.
So we want to make sure you
approach your talk, your video,
or your meeting with
that same attitude
that a performer would
approach their work.
ARJITA SETHI: Sounds like we are
ready for our tip number one.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Warm-ups!
ARJITA SETHI: Let's start
with our voice and face.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Before I walk on stage.
ARJITA SETHI: Or into a meeting.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Or in front of
a camera, I warm up my voice.
This exercise is
called squish splat.
It's going to seem pretty
silly, and that's because it is.
ARJITA SETHI: Almost all
of these warm-ups are
a little off the wall in
the hopes of getting you
and your brain into
a playful mood.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And there's
plenty of science that
proves why that's important.
Visit the description
below to learn more
about the positive effects
of improv on your brain.
Now imagine you're
holding a ball of dough.
ARJITA SETHI: Like
beats of dough.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Now
you take that dough,
and you throw it against
an imaginary window.
And when you do, you
articulate it with Splat!
ARJITA SETHI: Splat!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Really
stick that tongue out.
Open your mouth as wide as
you can because after we
throw the dough,
we're going to grab it
back up from the window,
and squish it up.
ARJITA SETHI: Squish!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Perfect.
And really try to make sure
that your facial features all
squeeze together.
Make them a single point.
ARJITA SETHI: Squish!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Lovely.
Now back to Splat!
And make sure that you really
vocalize that-- Aaah-- part.
ARJITA SETHI: Splat!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Squish!
ARJITA SETHI: Squish!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: This is
going to be hard at first,
but over time, you'll get
more and more comfortable
making these weird blaaa faces.
ARJITA SETHI: And
eventually you will even
be able to look another
person in the eyes
and do this back and forth.
BOTH: Splat!
Squish!
Splat!
ARJITA SETHI: Until then,
try doing it in the mirror.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And this
is just one warm-up exercise
of many, so check
out the description
below for more helpful warm-ups.
ARJITA SETHI: And that
brings us to tip number
two-- always put a story
into your meetings, talks,
or presentations.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And
we're going to practice
telling a story with an
exercise we call portkey.
ARJITA SETHI: It helps
to get a random word
to inspire your story.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: OK, so the
random word is breakfast.
It's important to launch
into the story right away.
Don't sit, and
think for too long.
A story in motion tends
to stay in motion.
ARJITA SETHI: OK, breakfast.
So when I first came to San
Francisco about two years ago,
I had to make my own breakfast.
So now I had two choices.
Either I cook my
breakfast, which
meant I would burn,
melt, overcook,
spoil something, or
hunt down a place which
gave amazing breakfast.
And luckily, I found this
mom-and-pop shop right
beneath my apartment, which gave
these amazing bagels and cream
cheese and lovely coffee.
Well not lovely but then hunger
is the best sauce, you see.
Two months ago the
shop shut down,
and now I'm again on my hunt.
But I at least bought a
coffee maker, which gets me
up and running in the morning.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
So let's break down
what made that story
engaging and delightful,
using tip number three.
ARJITA SETHI: Feedback.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Feedforward.
In this exercise, we focus
on a series of questions,
starting with, how did you
feel telling that story?
ARJITA SETHI: Well
initially, it was strange
because I've never told
that story to anyone,
and I never thought I would be
telling that story to anyone.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Great.
How do you think
the audience felt?
ARJITA SETHI: I
think initially they
might not be so interested.
But as I got into
the story, I realized
it was a personal story, they
would have also wanted to know,
what's next?
CLAIRE SLATTERY: What did
you feel was successful?
ARJITA SETHI: I
think the ending.
I got a coffee maker
CLAIRE SLATTERY: What
made it challenging?
ARJITA SETHI: The beginning.
I mean, a random word breakfast.
I never thought I could
come up with a story.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: What
would you do differently?
ARJITA SETHI: I would ramble
less and be quicker, I think.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: OK,
that makes sense.
So you said it was a little
awkward at the beginning,
starting from the
random word breakfast
and that you had never
told the story before.
But once you got started, you
felt like you kind of got more
into it, the audience
started feeling
engaged, wanting to know
what was happening next.
And so you wanted to
keep that feeling.
So moving forward,
you want it to maybe
make it a little less rambly,
maybe a little more concise,
and you really
like you're ending,
the bit about the coffee maker.
And so I really want you to
stick the landing next time.
That felt a great last line.
ARJITA SETHI: That
sounds like feedforward.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Totally.
And as you can see, I was able
to help synthesize what Arjita
experienced, helping her
sort through the insights
and next steps.
ARJITA SETHI: OK, let's recap.
Tip number one-- warm-up.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Squish!
Splat!
ARJITA SETHI: Exactly.
And tip number
two-- tell a story.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And
finally, tip number three,
give feedback, feedforward.
ARJITA SETHI:
Thanks for watching!
CLAIRE SLATTERY: You can
check the description
below for links from Google
Developers, Women Techmakers,
and for more tips
from Speechless
on how to think
like an improviser
and develop your voice.
ARJITA SETHI: Ouch.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Sorry.